Suppose there are a handful of water
Separated by a semi-permeable membrane
But what does a semi-permeable membrane mean?
This means that some things are allowed to pass
And prevents the passage of other things
That is, this membrane resembles an outlet
Allow water molecules to pass
We will talk later about what is not allowed
Which makes it semi-outlet
Think about what can happen if it is
Water molecules are present on both sides
We talked about this in video-related videos
Since the concentration of water molecules is equal
On both sides, the probability of transmission is one
Of these molecules to this aspect in a specific time period
Is equal to the probability of another water molecule moving
From right to left in the same time period
This is due to the same emphasis
These things move
In different directions
At different speeds
We talked about probability
We said that the probability of moving from left to right
Through one of these gaps, is equal
The probability of moving from right to left
In a specified time period
But to make it interesting
We treat water as solvent
And we shall put the soliloquy therein
To melt
Let's put some of the solute particles here
We make it larger in size to see clearly
They will find it difficult to pass through these gaps
There are other cases where similar permeable membranes are used
The charge to allow some things to pass
Preventing others
But easy to imagine size
Think of the membrane as allowing only
The passage of specific objects of specific sizes
Let us put some of the melancholy here
this too
On the other hand, we place a particle or a particle on it
In fact let's increase the number of particles
In the right side
So that the dissolved concentration
Top in this aspect
This is a semi-permeable membrane
Clearly, the size of these gaps
These large particles will not be allowed to pass
Across the membrane
And therefore will not be able to spread
But if allowed to spread
These particles move toward the concentration gradients, from the higher concentration to the low concentration
These large particles are likely to be transported
From right to left is greater than the possibility of moving from left to right at any time
Because the number of particles is larger on the right side
But this membrane
Semi-outlet
Thus will not be allowed
The spread of these things
All these have large particles
Its own speed
So, what will happen?
Let's think about it
Large particles can not
Spread from side to side
But what happens to water molecules?
The water molecules will not stop, on the left side
About the movement
If it moves to the right side
It can move from the left side to the right
And moves to the right side through these gaps
But what about the molecules on the right side?
If appropriate conditions exist
This molecule may pass through the membrane
And so we get the
Water molecules move back and forth
But we can say that probability
Transmission of water molecules
From left to right side, less than
The possibility of moving from the left side to the right
What is the reason?
These large molecules are unable to propagate
Intervene in this matter
They are moving
And sometimes prevented
Access these openings
If this membrane is not present, it will not be inhibited
These molecules process access
But since the membrane exists
The particles may prevent the process from reaching or bouncing
Some water molecules are paid
Bound in this direction
Therefore we can say that some water molecules
You succeed in moving from right to left
But the possibility of moving from right to left
Less likely to move from left to right
Thus the water flow is clear from
This is the aspect in which the concentration of the solute decreases
The solvent is the substance
Dissolved in water
The solvent is general
Which is more
In this case water is the solvent
Water is probably the most common solvent
The solubility is less
Accordingly, the solvent dissolves in the solvent
Water molecules migrate clearly
Of this solution in which the solute concentration decreases
To the other, where the concentration of melted is high
This phenomenon is called osmotic property
There are other examples of osmotic properties
This has been observed over and over again
If we put something familiar to fresh water
It has skin or membranes
Allow water to pass, in salt water
Such as a slaughtered animal
It will not do well in the presence of salt
Because the water in the slugs does exactly
What happens in this illustration
We have talked about this mechanism before
The molecules that can not pass through the membrane
And prevents the movement of water molecules from right to left
And continue to bounce, may cause moving water molecules
Located on the left side
To this trend when they bounce back
This is one interpretation
But there is another possibility that is often
The solvent is dissolved in water
Shipment associated with it
Take table salt as an example
So we have sodium ions
Salt is sodium chloride
But when placed in water, we get sodium ions
Chloride ions
Chloride ions are negative
Sodium ions are positive
Away from the idea of ​​mechanical blockage
We mentioned it, there is another idea
Since these are ionic molecules and carry loads
Water also carries partial shipments
It may stick to more water molecules
So the water molecules that stick to it will not be able
From passing through the membrane
But what does water mean?
The water molecule consists of
An oxygen atom carries a partial negative charge
And two hydrogen atoms
Lyndon is so, if hydrogen atoms
Carry a partial positive charge
The oxygen tip is attracted
Far from hydrogen
To the sodium molecule
Thus the sodium molecule can not pass through it
The oxygen tip wants to stick to the sodium molecule
You can imagine the attraction of all these water molecules
To the sodium molecule
Reducing the likelihood of the molecules moving
From right to left compared to their probability of transmission
From left to right
Well, if we have negative ion charge like this
We can direct water to the other side
Where hydrogen particles are attracted by a partial negative charge
To chloride ion located here
Since the chloride ion will not be able to pass through
This reduces the likelihood of transit
These particles are attached to it
The attraction of these molecules to
More chloride or sodium ions
From its attraction to other water molecules
Partial shipments
These fully charged particles will not be able to pass
And the probability of passing these molecules as well
Be slim
But this has double implications
I hope one of you shows me a simulation
Good or we can work simulated for this
Using the Khan Academy of Computer Science program
The probability is that
The passage of water molecules from left to right
Are more likely to be moved from right to left
This is due to mechanical blockage or these large particles
Which bounce and push the water molecules in the wrong direction
Or attraction of water molecules to these large molecules
They carry a cargo
This is the Osmotic property